E aí
[Música]
e quando eu tinha aproximadamente 10
anos a proprietária da Perfumaria onde a
minha mãe costumava comprar a grande
maioria dos nossos produtos cosméticos
transmitiu uma mensagem que me acompanha
até os dias de hoje a dona Açucena
recebemos sempre na sua pequena
perfumeria a uma perfumaria típica do
início dos anos 90 com as paredes
cobertas a vitrines vitrines douradas
com os focos de luz a realçar a beleza
das Embalagens dos perfumes dos
expositores da maquilhagem naquele
ambiente tem o perfume da mistura de
todas as fragrâncias dos Cosméticos que
estão no seu interior confesso que
guarda esse aroma no meu banco de
memórias olfativas até o dia de hoje
tenho a certeza que está imortalizado na
minha memória e ainda bem a mensagem que
ela me passou foi bastante simples mas
de fato a película até o e
ela disse que quando o nosso vá tão
acaba e já não somos capazes de aplicar
diretamente nos nossos lábios na
realidade o batom ainda não acabou e se
nós quisermos com a ajuda de um simples
pincel conseguimos continuar a escavar
no batom e temos ali produto para mais
uns quantos meses e facto é verdade há
portanto esta mensagem serviu para eu
perceber que as marcas não nos dizem
tudo nos rótulos e eu sempre adorei ler
os rótulos dos produtos cosméticos
sempre fiz e também que uma mensagem
como esta nos dá uma sensação de
esperteza como se nós fossemos mais
espertos do que as marcas porque fato
não obtemos através delas essa
informação mas tem de encontrar Nossa
curiosidade podemos descobri-la e porque
não mudarmos nossos hábitos foi
exatamente isso que me aconteceu eu
considero que este terá sido o primeiro
contato que eu tive com a
sustentabilidade a médica e mudou de
facto da forma como eu trabalho nesta
indústria
terminou eventualmente a minha carreira
para falar sobre a sustentabilidade na
cosmética e acredito que as marcas que
têm o dever de adotar todos os
consumidores da informação necessária
para a maximização da utilização dos
produtos cosméticos que é muito
importante e acredite Sem dúvida que a
educação para quase tudo na vida é chave
e uma mensagem certa passada da forma
correta independentemente da idade pode
mudar comportamentos e consequentemente
mudar o mundo nós não viveríamos neste
mundo sem cosméticos é um facto os
cosméticos acompanhamos desde sempre a
história da humanidade é coincidente com
a história dos Cosméticos como bem sabem
e portanto os cosméticos tem um papel
determinante para a nossa saúde hoje em
dia Organização Mundial da Saúde de fim
de saúde não só como a doença mas também
como um estado pleno de bem-estar físico
psíquico e social e sim inclui
naturalmente a integração de cada
sujeito individual no meio em que vive
portanto segundo a definição de
cosméticos nesta classe incluem várias
categorias de produtos que certamente
utilizarão no vosso dia a dia a pasta de
dentes o desodorizante o protetor solar
o creme hidratante todos os produtos de
maquilhagem o sabonete das mãos o
perfume etc portanto uma panóplia de
produtos que realmente nós utilizamos e
os benefícios funcionais dos cosméticos
são inquestionáveis nós precisamos de um
sabonete para lavar as nossas mãos e
evitar a propagação de doenças como Já
percebemos nós precisamos de uma pasta
de dente fica para lavar os dentes e
evitar o desenvolvimento de cáries e
doenças gengivais
é mas é mais do que isto setenta e dois
por cento das pessoas afirmam que os
cosméticos são essenciais para a sua
qualidade de vida
74 por cento referem que os cosméticos
são cruciais para a construção da sua
autoestima e 85 porcento das pessoas
sentem-se mais confiantes quando sabem
que estão a utilizar cosméticos em
Portugal cada pessoa utiliza em média
dez cosméticos por dia o mercado europeu
dos Cosméticos é o maior do mundo mas
Portugal está longe de ser o país que
mais consome cosméticos como é óbvio que
nós atravessarmos para outro continente
e fomos até os Estados Unidos da América
85 por cento das mulheres utilizam 16
produtos cosméticos por dia e por ano
Gastão
330 mil milhões de euros em produtos
cosméticos O que é mais ou menos uma vez
e meia o produto interno bruto
e
portanto é bastante
nós vivemos uma crise global de resíduos
não há dúvidas disto a cosmética tem
nesta crise o impacto brutal e por por
ano são criados 120 mil milhões de
embalagens
O que significa que desde que eu comecei
a falar até agora já foram criadas
aproximadamente
meio milhão de embalagens no mundo
o tanto Isto é bastante nós temos que
aprender a viver com os Cosméticos de
uma forma sustentável
porque realmente estes produtos são
todos produzidos por que nós os queremos
consumir e criamos um círculo vicioso de
consumir oferta onde realmente a maior
vítima acaba por ser o nosso planeta um
pouco à semelhança de toda a sociedade
de consumo nós vivemos com o excesso de
produtos cosméticos que em primeiro
lugar não faz bem a nossa pele não faz
bem as nossas Finanças e não faz bem ao
nosso planeta portanto nós temos uma
produção endêmica de gases poluentes de
resíduos Associados a este consumo e
portanto O Grande Desafio para o século
21 será nós como indivíduos conseguimos
estar bem atendendo Atualmente as
necessidades de todos não prejudicando o
planeta e aqui não prejudicar significa
olhar ou Consul e a emissão dos gases
poluentes EA biodiversidade sem
biodiversidade não existe humanidade
o tanto
sustentabilidade é um conceito muito
vasto a a sustentabilidade aplica-se aos
cosméticos como é óbvio foi um termo que
surgiu de desenvolvimento sustentável
que tem exatamente a ver com o bem-estar
da geração atual sem comprometer as
gerações futuras e naturalmente isto
passa pela preservação do planeta a
sustentabilidade É uma longa viagem com
várias dimensões uma dimensão ambiental
uma dimensão económica e uma dimensão
social e portanto há muito que se diga e
muito trabalho a fazer para nós termos
de sustentabilidade na cosmética durante
todo o ciclo de vida de um produto
cosmético a impacto na sustentabilidade
desde o desenvolvimento do produto a
seleção dos ingredientes
e a cadeia de produção ao embalamento
tentar parte de acondicionamento
embalagem a sua distribuição ou consumo
e depois ao descarte das próprias
embalagens estão neste ciclo nós temos
de facto um impacto tremendo em primeiro
lugar a questão que se coloca é não
deveriam as empresas colocar no mercado
cosméticos que fossem sustentáveis para
o consumidor não ter que se preocupar
tanto com isto obviamente que sim se
existe a luz atual ciência capaz de
fazer com que as marcas que queria em
produtos sustentáveis em quase todas as
categorias assim a si as marcas o fazem
nem sempre e aqui acaba por ser um pouco
uma opção nós temos grandes grupos de
indústria cosmética com várias marcas e
nesses mesmos grupos nós temos marcas
onde são aplicados princípios de
sustentabilidade
e onde isto não acontece se a
sustentabilidade fosse de facto uma
prioridade para a indústria ela seria
aplicada de uma forma de transversal e
não é
portanto numa sociedade de consumo onde
nós investimos o nosso dinheiro também
que ela por ser um voto por isso como
consumidores nós podemos e devemos
investir em marcas que tenham uma
preocupação ecológica e sustentável
escolher produtos escolhendo a forma
como elas comunicam essa
sustentabilidade
e olhando para o ciclo vida novamente
queria dizer na parte do consumo
propriamente dito os produtos cosméticos
é onde a data de hoje existe mais
Impacto então nós como consumidores
também temos um papel a fazer e são boas
notícias por que significa que só
depende de nós Nós aprendemos a fazer a
coisa da forma correta vamos
efetivamente fazer só para vos dar um
exemplo
setenta por cento das embalagens de
produtos cosméticos são deitados ao lixo
sem estarem terminados
e tenta por cento no ciclo de vida de um
champô
95% da pegada carbónica vem depois de
nós comprarmos o produto cosmético
Vamos aprender a fazer escolhas mais
sustentáveis como o guia simplificado
para a escolha dos Cosméticos
sustentáveis
então eu vou começar com o óbvio que é
não utilizar produtos super fofos
a sermos mais Racionais nas nossas
compras avaliaremos se realmente não
estamos a escolher produtos cosméticos
com funções sobreponíveis e redundantes
por exemplo antonico uma essência uma
água floral e depois tudo o resto não é
portanto escolher e uma forma racional
receber se vamos realmente utilizar
aquele produto e fazer então a nossa
escolha não é por nós temos
possibilidades para comprar tudo e mais
alguma coisa que nós temos ou devemos
comprar tudo e mais alguma coisa não é
por nós sempre temos feito de uma
determinada maneira que temos que fazer
sempre da mesma maneira nós podemos
mudar esse quando sabemos fazer melhor
Vamos fazer melhor está nas nossas mãos
depois de já termos analisados a fizemos
a nossa escolha racional vamos optar por
comprar o cosmético que é que nós temos
analisar a origem dos ingredientes e
aqui ao mito muito grande maior parte
das e aqui os produtos sintéticos não
são não são sustentáveis e que os
naturais é que são sustentáveis isto não
é verdade
sustentabilidade não é sinônimo de
naturalidade existem vários ingredientes
de origem natural que tem de facto um
impacto grande na sustentabilidade o
óleo de palma A Mica e os óleos
essenciais que estão tão na moda e
normalmente fazem parte da cosmética
pseudo sustentável mas que não são nós
precisamos para fazer um mililitro de
óleo essencial de uma quantidade de
Gigante de uma planta portanto Cuidado
para não confundirem de facto destes
conceitos depois
para além da origem dos ingredientes
naturalmente a forma como o produto se
apresenta a cosmética sólida e
consequentemente com menor consumo de
água é bastante interessante do
conquista da sustentabilidade a água é o
nosso recurso mais precioso pelo ainda o
futuro virá a sua escassez e portanto
tudo o que nós podemos fazer para
utilizar cosméticos com menos água
melhor em média nos produtos cosméticos
água é o ingrediente principal
lerem os ratos conseguem comprovar isto
que vem logo normalmente no primeiro
lugar corresponde aproximadamente de 60
a 85 porcento de uma forma de um produto
cosmético e portanto o que nós podemos
fazer para a poupar tanto melhor isto
tem também o impacto em outros
ingredientes da formulação uma forma que
tenha menos água ter a menor necessidade
de conservantes e Isto pode ser
interessante para as peles mais
sensíveis que muitas vezes acabam por
ter sensibilidade alguns dos
conservantes utilizados em cosmética que
são absolutamente essenciais presentes
os médicos devem conter conservantes Mas
se for uma pequena quantidade melhor
depois já que estamos a falar dos
sólidos falar-vos da do formato
propriamente dito a maior parte dos
sólidos Av e apresenta-se um formato
Redondo mas depois vem numa embalagem
quadrada Isto é muito mal de contexto
adote-me zação do espaço Portanto o
ideal seria nós termos um cosmético
quadrado dentro de uma embalagem
quadrada um Redondo dentro da embalagem
Redonda porque se vocês pensarem ser um
formato Redondo dentro de uma embalagem
quadrada a uma área que fica sem estar
aproveitada a que pensando um sabonete a
área que não está a ser aproveitada se
tivesse efetivamente fórmula cosméticos
daria para mais de 30 utilizações então
não estamos a gastar dinheiro e recursos
basicamente para transportar ar bom
então pequenas coisas que nós
efetivamente se olharmos quando sabemos
podemos mudar depois a
multifuncionalidade se não escolhemos
cosméticos multifuncionais também
estamos a otimizar todos estes recursos
e aqui um blush pode ser um batom um
condicionador pode ser uma máscara um
shampoo pode ser um gel duche E por aí
fora a multifuncionalidade ajuda
bastante na questão da sustentabilidade
comprar o local
que é facto vale para tudo mas para os
cosméticos também nós temos muita
tentação encomendar online produtos
cosméticos que já encontramos calhar na
nossa loja do bairro na nossa farmácia e
etc portanto se nós privilegiamos o
comércio local que está mais perto de
nós e isto é válido para a cosmética
como é óbvio estamos efetivamente a ter
uma atitude sustentável
e depois a seleção dos materiais para
embalagem nós sabemos que a maior parte
dos Cosméticos vem em embalagens de
plástico o plástico tem muitas vantagens
mas do ponto de vista da
sustentabilidade está longe de ser o
melhor material para embalagem já
existem opções muito mais sustentáveis e
noventa e nove porcento de plástico
Continuar a ser obtido através de
derivados petroquímicos quarenta por
cento é de uso único e menos de 10
porcento é reciclado e aqui também uma
mensagem importante e que muitas vezes
faz parte de um determinado Bruno o fim
da indústria
reciclado é diferente de reciclável Nós
lemos muitas vezes reciclável reciclável
muito bem mas reciclado ainda melhor
significa que já teve uma vida e pode
voltar a ser usado foi voltado a ser
usado aqui também em relação aos
ingredientes
reutilizáveis o upcycling que muitas
vezes faz Porto a utilizar na cosmética
ingredientes que vêm de outras
indústrias por exemplo os óleos vegetais
romã de abóbora etc e as marcas
comunicam isto nós tivemos curiosidade
em ler é obviamente vantajoso para as
marcas transmitirem esta origem dos
ingredientes de reaproveitamento do
ponto de vista da sustentabilidade e
pois também somos muito impactado com o
papel que também tem uma pegada
carbónica muito considerável
recentemente Tem havido uma grande
tentativa das marcas em comunicar em
embalagens que parecem ser de papel mas
que não são na realidade nós não podemos
ter um creme dentro de uma embalagem de
papel foram solo e podemos mas um creme
não conseguimos E então muitas vezes as
marcas trocam plástico por um material
que parece papel mas que não é 100
porcento papel aquilo que nos parece
papel fora por dentro tem um plástico e
a data de hoje Continuar a ser mais
simples nós fazemos o tratamento as
imagens que sejam monomaterial mesmo que
até seja plástico do que uma mistura de
vários materiais
idealmente também faríamos o refil e
aqui já temos muitas opções no mercado e
é ótimo facto é um grande passo para a
sustentabilidade e sem comprometer a
sustentabilidade EA segurança porque são
conceitos interligados também o granel
quando falamos de cosméticos e
sustentabilidade nós temos sempre que
atenderá a segurança um cosmético por
lei tem que nos transmitir uma série de
mensagens na sua rotulagem e portanto
quando compramos a granel e a parte de
trás a embalagem nós temos que garantir
que quando levamos o produto para casa
temos essa informação de como consumir a
origem lote etc mas o granelli Eu
Acredito que para a parte do nosso
futuro próximo E aqui as entidades
também naturalmente que vão regular tudo
isso portanto há uma série de coisas nós
podemos fazer em relação as embalagens
em relação a coleção continua a ser mais
fácil materiais em embalagens que sejam
de cores claras que que sejam
transparentes que tenham rótulos
pequenos que não tenham papel no seu
interior quando Compramos uma embalagem
com os folhetos as brochuras no interior
a primeira coisa que nós fazemos quando
abrimos o produto é deitar fora portanto
aquela informação podia estar no
interior da embalagem secundária não
precisava de estar ali mais papel nós
como consumidores podemos atender a
esses detalhes e naturalmente fazer as
nossas escolhas e depois alguns
programas que algumas marcas têm de
objeto e portanto também porque não
privilegiar os essas atitudes apoio a
causas sociais também a sustentabilidade
também tem essa dimensão social como vos
disse e portanto é extremamente
importante e por último só algumas dicas
complementares e já que muitas vezes nós
usamos cosméticos no nosso banho nos
importarmos a duração dos banhos
e nós reduziremos 1 e 2 graus na
temperatura do banho se aproveitarmos a
água fria que cai antes de vir a água
quente para regar as plantas ou até na
sanita estamos a ter uma atitude
sustentável
se cortarmos o nosso cabelo também
estamos a ter uma atitude sustentável
porque gastamos menos produto e gastamos
menos água e encostamos a duração dos
banhos portanto há uma série de coisas
que nós podemos fazer
aquando da utilização dos cosméticos
para nos tornarmos mais sustentáveis
e a sustentabilidade É uma longa viagem
efetivamente nós não podemos querer
mudanças de um dia para o outro mas Cada
esforço que nós fizemos em direção a
sustentabilidade será um passo para um
futuro melhor por uma questão de
coerência os cosméticos refletem o nosso
estilo de vida e até a nossa
personalidade portanto ser sustentável É
não ser Consumista aquilo que nós
comprarmos vamos usar até o fim e mesmo
que as marcas não nos digam qual é o
verdadeiro fim do produto como acontecia
no meu batom cabe a nós investigar ir
até o encontro deste fim e claro fazer
como a dona a cena que apesar tudo e até
numa atitude bastante altruísta para uma
proprietário de um estabelecimento
comercial me ensinou um truque tão
simples mas capaz de mudar hábitos e
consequentemente fazer a ação dos
Cosméticos seja boa para o nosso corpo
Mas acima de tudo que nos faça bem a
consciência
E aí
[Música]